juan soto was reached in all eight games
on this road trip
juan soto
center field
apple's gone
two runs shot off the bat of juan soto
lefty lefty match up does not phase him
a bit and the nationals are on the board
here in the first inning i'll make it
all eight of juan soto's home runs on
the road
dan this is exactly what i'm talking
about he's staying with the pitches he's
driving the way they're pitched
he's not trying to pull everything
[Applause]
this fastball center cut right down the
middle and anytime you take a fastball
and you drive and take a pass while in
the middle of the plate and are you able
to drive it right up the middle straight
away dead center that's a picture
perfect swing for monsotto tough to get
out
and that is ball four he walks meadows
on four straight pitches how about that
margaux who walked goes to third diaz
who walk goes to second
and meadows takes over at first on a
four-pitch wall
randy arose arena
who's about to step in
there's a shot back into center field
roadways will go back and that baby is
going to be off the wall
margot scores diaz scores
throw to the plate
diaz
is in there with a second run
meadows winds up at third and somehow a
rose arena remains at first
wow 3-2 to brasso and he shoots it into
left
schwarber is going to make the catch the
tag at third
meadows will score and the rays take a
3-2 lead
so braussell
worked along at bat there he drives in
the go ahead run
[Music]
ground ball infield in
laos gonna take care of that before
they're
dangerous hitter and turner right there
breaking pitch got him a little tap the
runners hold second and third that's a
big pitch
and he got him
flipped down to first oh careful there
but he's throw a little wide to the foul
side but that completes the
strikeout and the ending here's him
getting back-to-back starts maybe adding
those two numbers up to get to eight
ryan zimmerman right field
at the wall
it's gone
ryan zimmerman's tied this game here in
the top of the third inning solo home
run his seventh long ball of the season
well maybe mcclanahan's favorite number
will be number eleven idolizing ryan
zimmerman after this 111 mile per hour
111 101 mark brower bullet to the
opposite field on the fastball 97 up and
away
bad rugby
this one drilled left field schwarber
back and he has it
so the race barreling a few balls up in
that inning but patrick corbin posts his
second straight zero still 3-3
phillips
against the left-hander
the runner goes the pitch is high in the
throw it's not going to be a time it
hits walls he's up and out his way to
third
quickly and there's no play there
a stolen base for walls and he winds up
at third
picks up his second stolen base of his
major league career
sam hit a no doubt opposite field home
run back in the third
ryan zimmerman to left field
this ball is way gone
a two-run shot for zim has given the
nats the lead here in the fifth
two homers in three innings and ryan
zimmerman keeps on crushing southpaws
well davey said he doesn't want the
900-foot home run but i think he'll take
the 393-foot variety there
taylor walls will lead off
high shot
deep into right center got a chance to
go
home run
taylor walls has hit his first major
league home run and that will make it
5-4
well the young shortstop hit the ball
deep in the
second inning to center and this one
well tagged to right center
little question about that about contact
wendell no official advance against
hudson
there's a shot
deep in the right and this game is tied
home
[Music]
joey wendell a pinch hit home run it's a
five-five ball game a rolling slider and
watch this just get absolutely
demolished by joey wendell
now you talk about barrel and a baseball
and that dugout knew
you can see what the nats can do
man in scoring position again here let's
find a way with two strikes put in play
there he goes to right fields
harrison's in
soda will stop at third
and a great job by john gomes with two
strikes of leveling off and giving the
nationals a 6-5 lead
[Music]
kyle schwarber to left field
[Music]
backing up his meadows at the wall he
has it
soto will tag and score
and gomes will tag and move up as well
a shot to center field
well tagged does he have enough that
ball is going to be in play off the
glove and wall
here comes one running to score
rosarina's going to go all the way to
third and just like that it's a one-run
game
with the infield in it's wendell at the
plate
one and one
and a base hit lined into right center
field here comes the tying run wendell
the big turn at first and he ties it
again
it's a 7-7 ball game
and starlin castro will get things
started for the nats here off diego
castillo
and castro ropes this one to left field
on the first pitch off the very top of
the wall
mercer will score easily castro into
second ahead of the throw
and one pitch into the 11th the nats
have an 8-7 lead
well dan one pitch in 111 miles an hour
off the bat
the o2
harrison fly ball
out towards left center kier meyer is
going to get behind it
castro tagging
the throw nut in time
the nationals have a two run lead here
in the top of the 11.
well done by josh harrison with two
strikes to put that ball in play
comes another one-two
slider got him swinging
well it took a while but the nationals
pick up a huge win in the second game of
this short two game series at the trap